The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: Hello and welcome.
So today I want to start to talk
about discrete time systems.
But before beginning there, I
want to say just a quick word
about homework.
I tried to stress this
last time that the way you
get to know this stuff
is by doing the homework,
and we'd like to provide
positive feedback
in a direction that
will help you get
the most out of the homework.
So to that end, we've
already talked about there's
two kinds of problems.
Each homework will have
tutor problems that
are intended to be problems
like you will see on an exam,
but they will also
have the feature
that they can be
automatically graded
so that you can get immediate
feedback about whether you're
doing it right or not.
There will also be harder
questions questions
that look more like
real world questions
so you don't think
that this class is only
about toy problems.
The idea is to give
you problems that you
can imagine running into.
Those are harder to grade
automatically so we won't.
Instead they'll be
graded by a human.
Those problems often admit
several different lines
of reasoning.
So there isn't
necessarily a unique right
way to think about it.
So what we would like to do is
encourage you to-- after you
finish the homework--
read the solutions.
Now we think it's kind of an
impediment to wait for a week
till you get your graded
homework back because people--
in my experience--
just don't bother.
So what we would like to do is
post the solutions immediately
after your solutions are due.
Your solutions are due-- if
you submit electronically--
at 5:00 p.m.
on the due date.
So homework one is due
tomorrow, 5:00 p.m.
electronic submission.
You can also turn in paper.
You have to do that
in your recitation.
Immediately after it
was due at 5:00 p.m.
we'll post the
solutions, and we'll
encourage you, in
quotes, to read them,
because it's good
for you, right?
We hope that that will help you
find the errors that you made,
but also expose you to other
ways that maybe will be
simpler, maybe will be harder.
Your feedback on your
coming up with a simpler way
would be greatly appreciated,
so please send me email anytime
you think you have a
better way of doing things,
which is entirely possible.
But as further
encouragement, if you mark up
all of your errors
and resubmit, we'll
give you back half of
the points you lost.
So you get to submit
every homework twice.
Once for the due date
5:00 p.m. on Wednesday.
Immediately after
that, you'll be
able to see the
published solutions.
You can circle all the errors
and say algebra, or conceptual,
or I'm an idiot, or whatever
is the right way of thinking
about what you did.
And if you get
all of the errors,
you'll get back half
of the points you lost.
If you say, I'm
right, you're wrong,
maybe you won't get
all your points back.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The resubmission
is the same rules.
If you want to
submit by paper, you
can turn them in on
Friday's recitation.
You have until Friday
at 5:00 p.m. otherwise.
Please notice that,
if you're using paper,
we will not have returned
your solutions in time for you
to write on them,
so make a copy.
If you want to do
the paper route,
make a photocopy before you
turn it in the first time,
so that you have something to
write on for the second time.
If you submit
electronically, there's
a feedback button on the
tutor, so you can see the thing
that you just submitted.
So that's not a
problem if you're
doing the electronic thing,
but if you're doing paper,
please, make a photocopy
before you submit.
Otherwise, it will be hard
to mark up your solutions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, but you
should probably tell us
what you'd like us to do.
We would normally try
to make our best guess.
So if you turn in everything
in the paper copy,
we will look at your
previous submissions,
but it would be best if
you said some remark like,
this overrides the
electronic submission,
or please ignore problems 1
to 4, just make sure we know.
We're going to try to do
what you want us to do.
Other issues about logistics?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So just
to make sure, we
don't have to submit
homework both electronically
and in paper?
PROFESSOR: No, absolutely not.
If you do the electronic
route-- which is the preferred,
we like electronic because
it won't get lost--
the graders will absolutely
have access to it
because they're
all in one place.
We like the electronic route,
but if you'd prefer paper,
just make sure you give us paper
and one or the other suffices.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Did we ever submit
the tutor questions on paper?
PROFESSOR: You don't need to.
If you submit the
tutor problems online
and it says you're 100%
correct, you're done.
We don't ever need
to see anything else.
You've got full credit.
Other issues?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If people are
having technical problems
with the tutor, please tell us.
Don't just feel like
you have to kick out
and do the paper version.
We're trying make
sure that everything
is in place this week.
PROFESSOR: We will try
to be very responsive.
As I told you, this
is a brand new tutor.
We're very optimistic about
it, but we're also realistic.
Software has bugs,
but don't tell
any of my software people--
my software friends-- that.
Software has bugs,
so we're trying
to get rid of all of ours.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry?
PROFESSOR: You have to shout
because my hearing is gone.
AUDIENCE: What happens if you
run out of submits on tutor?
PROFESSOR: If you run out
of submits, that's bad.
During this sort
of ramp up phase,
just send us an email,
because the goal is not
to have you run
out of submits yet.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if you
run out of submits
and your last submission
was an incorrect answer
and [INAUDIBLE] that
has the correct equation
for that answer, will you
still get full credit?
PROFESSOR: If you
continue to hit submit,
we will continue
to be aware of it.
It's all in the grade.
We know everything you've done.
So just go ahead and hit
submit some more times.
You can always turn in
paper to override it,
or you can always
send me an email
and say, I ran out of
submits, the answer is blah.
We're going to try to
be very cooperative.
This is new.
This is supposed to be helpful.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's not supposed
to be on your website.
That's supposed to
be on my website.
I'll have to look into that.
If it works, use it.
OK, other obvious
errors that we've made?
OK, let's go on
and talk about 003.
What I want to do today--
last time, I
introduced what I call
the 6.003 abstraction which
is the idea that we represent
a system--
whatever it is-- by the way
it transforms an input signal
to an output signal.
The goal for today is
to start to develop
machinery that takes advantage
of that representation.
We'll start by
thinking about DT.
DT is conceptually
easier than CT.
That's why we start there.
Algebra is slightly
easier than calculus.
That's the idea.
What we learn in DT will
transfer almost verbatim
into CT.
CT is like DT but
a little harder
so there is some extra stuff,
but the things we learned in DT
will still be applicable in CT.
Discrete time, continuous time.
Furthermore, DT
is just important.
So, increasingly,
applications of this field
are in discrete time.
That wasn't necessarily
true 20 years ago.
It's still the case that
there's lots of applications
that are intrinsically
married to the physics that
underlie it.
That makes it intrinsically
CT, but a lot of stuff
is done in DT.
So for a lot of reasons, we're
going to start with DT first,
and we're going to look
today at several different
representations of DT.
In particular, we're going to
look at difference equations
and block diagrams.
And we're always interested
in verbal descriptions,
because that's the way the
real world is described to you.
So what we want to do
is understand these.
Understand there are
strengths and weaknesses,
so that we can capitalize
on their strengths,
and go around their weaknesses.
That's the idea.
So the easiest
possible representation
is a difference equation.
Difference equations are good
because they are absolutely
precise, and they are the
absolutely most concise
representation we will have.
Precise and concise.
Those are good features.
So here's an example.
What if my output Y were my
input X minus X, n minus 1.
Let's say that the
input is a unit sample.
We will often ask for
the unit sample response.
The unit sample signal is the
most simple non-trivial signal
that we can have.
It is 0 almost everywhere,
and the only place it's not 0
is at 0, and when
it's not 0 it's 1.
So that's sort of the
easiest thing we can imagine.
So what we're going
to want to do then
is think about what
happens if we put
this signal into that system.
OK, that's completely trivial.
You've done this a
gazillion times before,
and now is your
chance to prove it.
How many of those statements
are true about the output
of this system when
that's the input?
Talk to your neighbor.
You've got 15 seconds.
Is it too simple?
Figure out how many of
those statements are true.
OK, you're either all
bored out of your minds
or paralyzed with fear.
I can't tell.
So everybody raise your hand.
How many of these
statements are true?
More hands, more hands, c'mon.
OK, less than half
correct, so I'll just
assume that you ran out
of time, and I'll go on.
So this is trivial, right?
What do I do?
How do I figure this out?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Step by step?
PROFESSOR: Step by
step, of course.
Yes, so if I think about
applying this equation
to that input, then I can
think about just substituting
n equals minus 1, n
equals 0, n equals 1,
n equals 2, et cetera.
And you can sort of
see that I'm only
looking at the input of
two instances of time.
So there's a finite range
over which the input--
there's a finite
range of inputs that
can contribute to the output.
And in particular,
if I were to say--
if I were to substitute
n equals minus 1,
I would see that the output
of time-- y minus 1--
depends on inputs before
the delta function started.
So therefore the answer is 0.
If I look at the output of
time 1, the time 0 input is 1,
the time minus 1 input is 0.
So my total answer
is 1, et cetera.
This is very straightforward.
It's just plug and chug, and
what you see is a waveform.
From which is
pretty easy to infer
that Y2 is bigger than Y1,
so Y2 was bigger than Y1--
bigger in a math sense.
And Y3 is bigger than Y2--
not.
Y3 and Y2 are identical,
so that's not true.
Y2 and, in fact,
everything above that is 0.
That's true, and if you do a
little bit of manipulation,
you can show that this
must have also been true.
Everyone see that?
I'm assuming you've seen all
this sort of stuff before,
so I'm going to go through
it kind of quickly,
but the answer was 4.
4 of those statements were true.
It was just a refresher
on how to think
about difference equations.
By comparison, I want to
contrast a difference equation
on a block diagram.
This is the same system but
represented graphically.
Why would you want to do that?
Well there's advantages
and disadvantages.
This is a direct way of
expressing the system
if you wanted to
implement it in hardware.
So you can imagine building a
delay box, building an adder,
building an inverter,
and constructing
a piece of hardware that
does the computation.
So this is more like a
hardware realization.
It's not as compact as
the difference equation.
It has another idiosyncrasy
that we have to have,
the notion of rest.
When we say the system
starts at rest-- which
we will say all the
time, and in fact,
you can always assume
that unless we tell you
something to the contrary.
When we say a system is
at rest, what we mean
is that all of the delays in
the system start out being 0.
So at rest means that this
signal starts out at 0,
because that's the only--
there's only one
delay in the system.
Its output is initially 0.
So now we think about
the input chugging along.
So the input starts out being 1.
That means the inverted
input is minus 1.
That doesn't propagate
through the delay,
because we're still
at the instant
when the input just became
one for the first time.
So this one goes through, and
adds to this 0 to give us 1,
and our answer is 1.
Now the clock goes kachunk,
and at that instant,
the input changes from
1 to 0, because that's
what happens here.
And at precisely
the same instant,
the delay signal went from 0--
which it was because
it started at rest--
to minus 1 which was its
input just before kachunk.
Then-- after the
signal settle down--
this becomes 0, and this becomes
minus 1, and that's our output.
Then, again, kachunk.
The input doesn't change,
because it was zero.
It's still zero.
The output of the delay
goes from minus 1 to 0,
and after things settle
down, we get 0 at the output,
and that is a state
that persists.
So we have these two
different representations.
We have difference equations
and block diagrams,
so here's a question.
How are they different?
In particular, I've told
you the difference equations
are concise and precise.
Are there advantages
to a block diagram?
Talk to your neighbor.
Come up with a good hypothesis.
What's good about a
block diagram, anything?
So can anybody think of
something good about a block
diagram?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It changes
the [INAUDIBLE]
and it's easy to see
what's happening.
PROFESSOR: So it's easy to see.
So that could be something to do
with a graphic representation,
but it could be deeper too.
Can somebody say a deeper reason
why it might be easier to see?
So that might be a
very good-- that might
be a deep comment too.
Why might it be easier
to use the block diagram
than it is to use that
difference equation?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because equations
are broken down into steps?
PROFESSOR: How so?
AUDIENCE: So there's
[INAUDIBLE] and then
there's the feedback [INAUDIBLE]
difference equations are
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So that's
kind of right.
I'm wondering if you
could say, I mean,
you just do this, right?
You do this, and
then you do that.
What's the difference?
There's something very
different about these two
representations.
There is more
information in the bottom
than there is in the top.
Can somebody tell
me the information
that's available in
the bottom that's
not available in the top?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Actually
solving circuits
it becomes a lot easier to
use graphical representation.
PROFESSOR: Circuits,
graphical, but is there
additional information here
that wasn't available there?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The number
of signal paths?
PROFESSOR: Number of signal--
AUDIENCE: Paths
PROFESSOR: Paths.
Signal paths is a good idea.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is it that
X and negative 1 is 0?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Well that sort of
goes with specifying X, yes?
AUDIENCE: The structure
is more emphasized,
so you can just look at
it, and [INAUDIBLE] or not,
and it's more easy to
see structure [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It is easier, but
there's a very precise reason
why it's easier.
There's arrows.
Arrows tell you what to do next.
So the thing that's
different is that.
From the structure of the
arrows, everything starts here,
and you should worry about
what goes that way, and what
goes that way, and
what goes that way,
and how that comes
together there.
There's more information.
In computer science terms, we
would say that the difference
equation is declarative.
It tells you a
statement of fact,
not necessarily what
you can do with it.
The block diagram is imperative.
It tells you how
to do something,
and those are very different.
So the difference equation
is concise, precise,
and declarative.
The block diagram is imperative.
Do this, do this, do this.
It shows you the
signal flow path.
There's no question
about who causes what.
In this, we could be computing
X from Y or Y from X.
There's no indication other than
some convention-- some place--
that the x is the input.
That make sense?
So there's a very
big difference.
There's another step
we want to take.
So imperative and
declarative is one step.
Another step is lumping
things in the same sense
that we lump the coordinates
of a three space point
into a single thing called
a point, or in the same way
we make a vector
in linear algebra.
The idea is going
to be that we're
going to want to think about
whole signals at a time.
In the notation that we will
use, we will think about--
this will be the X signal,
this will be the Y signal,
and we can re-interpret
the block diagram
to be operations on signals
rather than operations
on samples.
So I'm trying to develop a
level of abstraction that
helps us predict the
way systems will behave,
so the next level of abstraction
I want to think about
is thinking about
whole signals at once.
So if we take this
signal idea, we
would say there's an X signal.
It gets operated
by this inverter
to give an inverted
signal, then this signal
goes through a delay box to give
us a delayed inverted signal.
The delayed inverted signal gets
added to the original signal,
and that gives us
an output signal.
So we think about the
nodes being whole signals,
and the boxes being operators
on signals, not samples.
That's a huge
difference, and to make
sure to be explicit about
that we'll develop a notation.
We will say there's
an operator R--
the right shift operator--
that operates on signals.
So we'll think about if X is the
whole input signal, not the nth
sample, the whole thing.
If X is a signal, we can
operate on it by the R operator.
We can apply R-- the right shift
operator-- to the signal X,
and generate a whole
new signal which
I'll call Y which will be
a shifted version of the X
signal.
OK, you all got that?
And that leads us then to
a concise representation
similar to the
difference equation,
but that has the features
of the block diagram.
Because it's imperative,
R operating on X
tells me start with
X and apply R to it.
There's a direction.
R applied to X is imperative.
It tells me what to do.
So this is a way that I
can make a notation that
is as concise as
difference equations,
but has the same imperative
feature as a block diagram.
So it's an improved
notation in that sense.
Make sure that you
know what it means.
If I said that Y is RX, how
many of the following is true?
Now you have to redeem yourself.
You were less than 50% right,
so now I want 90% right.
Oh, excuse me, not
how many, which?
OK, everybody raise
your hands, c'mon.
This is redemption time.
Wonderful, you're redeemed.
So you're about 100% correct.
So to think about that.
One easy way to think
about it is by example.
Examples can't prove
that something's true,
but they can quickly prove
that something's false.
So if you think about the
simplest possible signal--
say you had a unit sample.
If you applied R to that, it
would shift it to the right.
If it shifts it to the
right, it's pretty clear
that Y at time 1 is the
same as X at time 0,
and that's a feature
of this equation
and none of the others.
So that proves the
others are wrong,
and if you think
about it a little bit,
you can generalize
that argument to prove
that the second one is actually
true for all the cases.
So the idea then is
that we want to think
about this hybrid notation,
this operator notation,
and we want to think
about how to represent
simple systems that way.
So here's an example.
Say I have this system.
I can think about that as
the cascade of a system that
starts with X, X as a
signal, and this whole thing
gets turned into an operator.
That operator can be
written mathematically as 1.
This path added to
minus 1 times a delay
minus 1 times a delay, so
one minus R operating on X
gives me Y1.
Then a very similar system
operates on Y1 to give me Y2
and if the rules
of math apply, I
ought to be able to
substitute 1 minus RX for Y1
and get that expression.
And if the world
were nice and it is.
If the world were nice,
then this expression,
since it looks like
a polynomial in R,
might behave like
and it's pretty easy to convince
yourself that that's, in fact,
true.
So think about the
primitive definition.
Sample by sample, difference
equation, what should this do?
Well, there's a
difference representation
for this, which is here.
There's a difference
representation
for this, which I
can substitute twice
so I can generate an
equivalent difference
equation for the whole
thing, and then I
can think about term wise
translating all of those
into R expressions.
And I see that I
have proved the idea
that this particular
system at least
behaves as though the
operator expressions follow
the rules of polynomials.
So that's important
because you know
how to deal with polynomials.
If there's an isomorphism
between these kinds
of discrete time
signals and polynomials,
the fact that you
know how to deal
with polynomials
translates into you
already know how to
do systems, right?
So it's a very
powerful kind of thing
to draw an isomorphism
between two systems,
especially when you already
know how to do one of them.
So let's think about
equivalence a little more.
Here's another example.
So here is that
same system that's
composed of two cascaded
difference engines,
and the hypothesis is
that this is the same.
Two things I want you to see.
First, it should be
pretty clear that you
can see how you would
derive that thinking
about the system as
operators R. You should also
be able to derive the
equivalence by thinking
about the individual blocks
as difference equations,
but more importantly, I'm hoping
that you can see a caveat.
Assuming both are
initially at rest--
that will come up over
and over and over and over
again for exactly this reason--
the equivalence is only true
if they started that rest.
That's not quite the
right way to say it.
The equivalence is always
true if they start at rest.
That is precisely right.
If they start at rest it
will always be equivalent.
Can you think of why
they have to be at rest?
Why do they have to be at rest?
OK, smile.
It's not torture.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So if they weren't at
rest, the outputs of the delays
wouldn't necessarily be zero.
There is no simple
correspondence
between these two delays
and those two delays.
If I told you what
are these two delays,
it may or may not be possible to
make an equivalent system where
there are two
different numbers here.
Say this delay starts at 1,
and this delay starts at 7.
There may or may not
be a set of numbers
for the bottom
delays that will have
the same behavior as those
numbers did in a top system.
But what is guaranteed is
if they all start at 0,
everything's fine.
That's the reason
we put in the caveat
initially that both
systems start at rest.
The equivalence
that we talk about
is equivalence
starting from rest.
So think about these systems.
They are equivalent.
You can try to convince
yourself they're
equivalent by thinking about
operations on block diagrams,
but what I'd like you
to think about is,
they are a statement of what
property of polynomials?
The equivalence of
those two systems
is a statement about what
property of polynomials?
Is it the commutative property,
the associative property,
the distributive property, the
transitive property, or none
of the above?
OK, you're far too quiet.
Take a break.
Turn to your neighbor.
Tell your neighbor what
living group you're in.
Become accustomed to
talking to your neighbor,
and then figure this out.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: a equals
b means b equals a.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Or 5.
PROFESSOR: OK, what property
is being described here.
Everybody raise your
hand with some number.
Excellent, excellent.
More than 90% correct.
So the idea is that we write
this as an R expression.
So this system
says, start with X,
apply this operator to X. It's
a little confusing that one
goes left and one goes right.
So start with X,
apply this to X--
that's the 1 minus R operator--
then take whatever comes out,
and apply R again.
Similarly, down
here, start with X.
You've got the sum of two
things, an R in the top,
and an R squared
minus 1 in the bottom,
and the equivalence of those
is the distributive principle.
R distributes so
multiplication over addition.
OK, in the interest of
time, let me skip that.
That's an exercise that you
can work on on your own.
It's very straightforward.
What I want to do is talk about
another more slightly deeper
issue, and that's the difference
between recipes and constraints
for whole block diagrams.
So we can think about this
as a recipe in the sense
that we can take
the R operators,
and think about signals as the
composition of other signals.
So this says, add this
signal to that signal.
This signal is just the
delay of that signal.
minus 1 of that signal.
So you can think about,
there's a recipe start with X,
invert it, delay it, add
it to the original, that's
the output.
Let's contrast that to this.
This is harder.
So let's think about
the R operators.
What we can say here
is that this output
is composed of the sum
of two things, the input
and the delayed
version of the output.
That's a recipe for finding
the input from the output.
That's not what we want to do.
So there's a recipe here that
says, start with the output,
shift it to the right, subtract
that from the original,
and that will tell
you the input.
But I don't know the
output, I know the input.
What that says is if
you knew the output,
it would have this property.
It's declarative.
Whatever the output is, it
has to have that property
but it didn't tell
me how to get it.
The R operator is imperative.
Start with the input, apply
R to it, you get the output.
But you can compose systems
using an imperative operator
that is not-- where the overall
system is not imperative,
so what are you going to do
with something like that?
Well it's a constraint,
so the question
is how do you think about that?
The thing to do in this case
is the thing you should always
do in this course.
Fall back to a simpler method.
The idea is we're going
to start by teaching
simple methods, then more
abstract methods and more
abstract methods.
The reason being that as the
methods become more abstract,
they become more powerful.
You can do things
quicker, but if they fail,
revert to the easier method.
So here the easier method
is sample by sample,
so let's just think
about how signals would
propagate through this system.
So think about this as a sample
by sample block diagram system.
Say that it starts at rest.
So the output before
any inputs come in
have to be 0, because
the initial condition was
that delays were all 0.
Now the input
comes in at time 1.
So X of 0 is 1, so the
output becomes one.
And now because of the way
the feedback path works,
the output as a
second signal is--
the second sample is also one.
Everybody see that?
And in fact, it's stuck.
So the idea in this system--
if you think about it
from a sample by sample point of
view, the signal at the output
persists long.
In fact, infinitely long
after the signal as the input
goes away.
That's very different from
what we saw in the simpler
systems that were imperative.
If in the previous system
you had a finite length
signal at the input,
any number of operations
that you did to it and
then combined those
would give you a
finite length output.
Maybe bigger than
the last one because
of extra delays in the system,
but if it started finite,
it's finite.
This is different here.
I'm having a persisting
response persists
to infinity from a transient
input and that's because--
it's because of feedback.
It's because there's a path
that wraps back on itself.
How do we think about that
in terms of R operators?
Well having figured out what
the response looks like,
there's a perfectly valid R
expression for this signal.
This is just the unit sample
plus R times the unit sample
plus R squared times the
unit sample plus R cubed
times the unit
sample, ad infinitum.
That's that system.
So I've done something very
powerful and not all that
obvious.
I've taken a system
that was not imperative,
and I've turned it into a
system that is imperative.
This system gives me a
recipe for how to do things.
Start with X, delay
it by one, and add
it delay by another one, and
add it delay by another one,
and add it delay it by
another one, and add it.
I've converted a
declarative statement
about how the system should work
into an imperative statement
about how the
system should work,
and I've got an equivalent
system representation
like this.
And you should be saying to
yourself, do I really buy that?
So is it really
going to be the case
that a system that was
previously described this way?
Tell me the output operate
on it by 1 minus R,
and that'll be the
input should that
be the same as this system.
If you think about that
mathematically, here's a proof.
It is OK to think
about it that way.
Start with the idea
that X2 equals X1.
This is a statement of
the right hand side.
Substitute X1 for X2.
Substitute this equivalent
expression for X1,
and multiply it out.
When you do that, you
find Y2 equals Y1.
It's true, and
what we've done is
showed a very important thing.
This and this are reciprocals.
When you multiply two
polynomials together
and the answer is one,
they're reciprocals.
So that implies that we can
treat that first expression--
we can think about this--
let's see, backup.
So here, we had an
expression that said,
start with the output, operate
on it with this, get the input.
We can think about that
instead as operate on the input
by the reciprocal operator.
Now I've defined what
this reciprocal mean.
Reciprocal means that
thing in the last slide,
so now I know from
the last slide
the reciprocal of 1 minus R
is 1 plus R plus R squared
plus R cubed, blah,
blah, blah, and that
follows the normal
rules of polynomials.
This is not a surprise.
You could have done that.
You could have derived
that same expression
by thinking about
synthetic division.
You could have thought
about it as a Taylor series.
Anything you know about
polynomials should have worked.
So this idea of representing
a signal by a system--
by an operator R--
is extraordinarily powerful.
We've been able
to take advantage
of non-trivial
properties of polynomials
by having done that, and
we'll continue that way.
So the overriding feature of
this system that was not--
that could not-- so this
system was not a recipe.
It was a constraint.
The feature that made
it that way is something
we'll call feedback,
and we'll be
able to visualize feedback very
simply by looking at the block
diagram.
Feedback means that
there's a cycle somewhere.
So if there's no
cycles then it has
to be-- so we call
this the network that
results when there's no
cycles, we say it's acyclic.
What a clever word, right?
So no cycles.
And when it's a acyclic,
it will have the property
that transient inputs give
rise to transient outputs.
If it has a cycle in it, then
it has feedback and feedback has
the potential-- doesn't always
do it but has the potential--
to generate a persisting
output to a transient input.
So if we think about a slightly
more complicated example where
I've put a number p0 in the
feedback loop that was not
in the previous example,
we can see that the way
you can conceive of this--
since there's a
single time when we're
thinking about the
unit sample response--
there's a single
input that's not 0.
And what you can do is
think about the feedback--
the block diagram--
you can think about
it separating times,
because there's one unit
of delay in every cycle.
So you can think about
that as the only way
you can get from the input at
times 0 to the output of times
0 is through the
straightforward path.
The one highlighted by red.
The only way you can get
from the input of times
0 to the output of times 1 is to
make the circle at least once--
to make the circle
exactly once there.
If you make the circle
exactly once then,
instead of being
height one, it's
height p0, because you had to
have gone through the p0 once.
If you go around a third
time, it's p-not squared,
p-not to the fourth, et cetera.
So there's a way of thinking
about why the way is there
this persistent response by
looking at the block diagrams.
What I'm trying to
emphasize is that it's
useful to be able to think about
difference equations, block
diagrams, R operators,
they're all useful.
What you want to know is the
strengths and limitations
of each.
So here what I've showed
is a very good way
to think about feedback in
terms of block diagrams.
How many of these
networks are cyclic?
networks are acyclic?
Is this cyclic?
This network?
No, so none of the paths
wrap that back on itself.
Here's a path.
None of those wrap on itself.
Is this network cyclic?
Sure, this is cyclic over here.
This one, Yeah.
The input, this is cyclic.
This one?
Doubly cyclic.
So that's the idea, and
this gives rise to a notion
that we will call a pole.
A pole is the base of
the geometric sequence
that results in these
simple sequences whenever
you have feedback, and we'll
be saying a whole lot more
about those in upcoming times.
In the interest of time,
I have to stop now,
but so the idea from
today is supposed
to have been lots
of representations
for DT signals, DT signals
and systems, strengths
and weaknesses of each,
difference equations--
concise, precise-- block
diagrams, visualizing signals
flow paths, operators, thinking
about things as polynomials,
and what we'll do in
the next few sessions
is try to build on that
polynomial representation
to gain further insights into
the way that systems will work.
Thank you.